[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui lui
l'évadé perpétuelle puis d'un monsieur
vous accuse de moeurs
une fois sur la guillotine moi je vous
dis je n'ai rien fait je connais le
coupable a libéré - jouira mails pour
lutter contre des soldats qui ne connaît
que le remaniement habitude lors de
l'été la 2 je ne suis pas vendeur
les besoins de résultats je voulais
courir
quelle grille mal-être de grâce à la
banque rien que ça
un voleur restant voleurs
les résultats restent des résultats
je me moque de savoir qui tu es
toi peut-être d'autre part
je peux
rendre de service
payant une lettre de menaces un gant
j'aime profondément votre conception de
la france fidèle
qu'est-ce que tu vivras toi quand tout
ça sera terminé
ces faits leno les empereurs de paris
jamais qu'un seul emprunteur
servir votre pays ou bien rester dans
l'ombre et la médiocrité
il va vous falloir choisir médoc